Are we rolling?
(laughing)
- Hi everyone... I'm Clark Backo.
- Lakeith Stanfield.
We're excited to introduce you to the new
Apple original series, The Changeling.
♪ Dramatic music ♪
How would you describe this show to a
friend?
- It's like a fantasy, horror, folklore.
- I'm following it.
In general it's a journey of two lovers...
doing everything they need to,
to... get their baby.
And the gravity of that.
- I hesitate to describe things.
- Yeah.
Just watch it, just turn it on and watch
it, watch it.
Let it... let it speak to you.
And you come up with your own
conclusions.
Y'all smart out there.
You don't need us!
Emma: When I got to... Brazil.
There was a lake there, a lagoon.
♪
They told me not to go, but I didn't
listen.
♪
Three wishes, before these knots are tied.
Don't cut it!
When it falls off my wrist, three wishes
will come true.
With me, all of your wishes will come
true.
♪ Intense music ♪
♪
Emma. Emma!
Doctor: Have you had any thoughts about
hurting yourself?
Emma: I just need to find... my way back
to myself.
Calisto: People call us witches.
You know the only real magic,
Apollo...
♪
is in the things you'll do for the ones
you love.
♪ Dramatic music ♪
Clark: Growing up, I've told you this
before, I loved...
Sci-fi fantasy, but I never really read
them.
And then would see a movie get made or a
TV show made...
With the imagination that I had, which is
someone wo looked like me.
- Mm. Mhmm.
- So one of the big reasons I loved
"The Changeling" was just reading a story
that is fantasy, and horror, and
beautiful, and knowing that...
there's people that look like us that are
the heroes.
Mhm. I wanna see, you know, Black
characters going through these journeys.
- And...
- Yeah, but they just happen to be Black.
But yeah, that's the crazy thing about
being Black.
All of us just happen to be
Black.
Lakeith: 'Cause it just really is a... a
human story.
I just had recently had a kid when I found
out about this story,
so I was just like, damn, I understand
that familial love.
It's a love unlike any other, but you
gotta like experience it
to know it... and so, you know, reading
this character felt like
he had lost that and had to go find
that and go through whatever
it takes to get there.
♪
I'm so excited for fans, because they're
gonna be, I think, pleasantly surprised
by this just beautiful world that we've
been able to create.
♪
I really don't think it's one of those
shows where people will guess...
- Nah, they ain't gonna get it.
- ...What's around the corner, ever.
Lakeith: Nah. Like when you see the show,
it looks amazing, it looks like
a different world that you're being zapped
into.
What did you see? After you did what was
asked of you?
You know what I saw.
Lakeith: If you don't pay attention, there
might be something that you missed,
that'll be a key thing to something else
You know, I like being excited by things
where I'm like
- oh I gotta pay attention just to see...
Clark: Yeah.
- how one key leads to another door.
- And maybe watch it a second time
And we'll see that in the end.
♪
What we doing here is real.
Lillian: A storm is coming.
♪
Emma: I'm scared for us.
No matter what happens,
you're coming with me.